jaina i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait
to see it all right
oh wow it's the slap that everyone is
talking about
e.t is learning new details about will
smith's mindset and he has no regrets
for sticking up for his wife at the
oscars oh
richard
oh wow
wow
will smith
in the wake of the infamous slap a
source tells e.t will does not regret
sticking up for jada but he does have
remorse for how he went about it he
acted out of impulse
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay this comes shortly after
will's apology to the comedian monday on
instagram i would like to publicly
apologize to you chris i was out of line
and i was wrong i am embarrassed and my
actions were not indicative of the man i
want to be as for jada whose face said
it all
jada i love you g.i jane too can't wait
to see it all right
our source says jade is glad that will
stood up for her because she was hurt by
the joke the source also tells et the
red table talk host was especially
sensitive in that moment since chris has
poked fun at jada in the past and
because she has struggled with alopecia
an autoimmune disorder which causes bald
spots and hair loss just all of a sudden
one day
and so it just showed up like that the
actress broke her silence on tuesday
posting this image to her instagram that
reads this is a season for healing and
i'm here for it as for the rest of the
smith family well the couple's daughter
willow also chimed in with her two cents
with a message of compassion you know
who's going through a lot right now
literally everyone just be kind
i want to apologize to the academy i
want to apologize to my all my fellow
nominees
so what's next we know chris has already
declined to file a police report but the
academy announced an investigation is
underway telling e.t in a statement we
have officially started a formal review
around the incident and will explore
further action and consequences
if i had to speak for my woman you know
i don't know if everyone handles
everything their own way
following the shocking moment reactions
were mixed at these star-studded after
parties
what were your thoughts
i thought it was a joke at first
you know
i would like to more of a straight
apology
to chris i thought will's performance
was amazing and i'm sorry that he
tarnished it with his behavior i seen a
man
stand up for his wife
which we don't see that much anymore
they put her face up on the screen
looked over at his wife she was hurt
will packer who produced the big show
spoke with e.t before the smackdown and
looking back seems like he had a feeling
the night would get people talking i
want people that haven't watched the
oscars in the years and have a reason to
tune in that's what i think we got
tonight
[Music]